we're very fortunate on this morning of
all mornings to bring in our chief
washington correspondent major garrett
to help us understand what's going on on
capitol hill major good morning to you
the president for monstered doubt and
anger over a supposedly stolen election
he whipped up his supporters to fight
like hell stormed the capital and now
he's condemning
violence what's his calculation here his
calculation quite simply tony is to try
to preserve what remains of his
legacy as president so it's not
incinerated before the public's eyes
by second round of insects
of violence perpetrated by his own
supporters
mayhem vandalism and violence the
president said he's been briefed
this city is completely on edge more
so than any inauguration or preparations
for inauguration i've covered since 1993
the sense of threat is very real not
just in this nation's capital
but in capitals around the country and
that's because of what you said the
president
has stirred up and continued to incite
for weeks upon weeks upon weeks
and he has got to try to find some way
to get control over that
if he can and if he doesn't all of the
blame will be on him
and his supporters and by extension the
republican party and republican leaders
in washington
are imploring the president do whatever
you can to tamp this down
if you can and that's where we are so
let's talk about those leaders in the
senate uh
the the president has been impeached it
would now take 17 senators
in the senate to convict and remove him
from office or censor him since he'll
already be gone
are there 17 senators who could do that
and mitch mcconnell has said he'll
consider it where do you think he'll
come down
17 republican senators on top of the 50
democrats would be assumed to
vote for removal from office but as you
said he would be out of office this is
all about
the things that you would hold after
being president and could you ever run
again those are real threats
to donald trump and former president
trump which he will soon be
and all of this i'm told tony is about
the majority leader mitch mcconnell
signaling to the president this is a
live
option this is a real threat to you and
your post presidency could be
severely limited not only in whether you
could run again
but all the emoluments that come with it
all the benefits you get as a former
president
if you don't stay within the guard rails
in the remaining time you have in the
white house and do everything you can to
prevent a second round of violence
this is the majority leader's way of
saying the president i haven't made up
my mind
this is a live thing for you and you
better take it seriously
and i know that republican leaders will
take every single utterance they can get
from this president video or otherwise
to try to tamp this down major a lot of
people are
expecting the biden administration to
come in with congress in their control
and
pass things to help the american people
how does impeachment
upset that agenda impeachment is real
it's an institutional response to an
attack on congress by the executive
branch
joe spiden knows that as an institution
congress cannot ignore that attack it
had to do
something impeachment was the remedy
chosen by house democrats the senate
will
have to have a trial what he can hope
for is that
the senate can walk and chew gum at the
same time do two things at once confirm
his cabinet appointees
start considering legislation and
conduct the impeachment trial let's be
honest the impeachment trial
is not that heavy a lift everyone saw
what happened everyone can make a
judgment about what the president said
and how that related to the violence
that occurred at the u.s capitol it's
not a complicated case
it won't take that much time the
incoming bite administration knows that
knows it has to be done
and knows it also has important work for
the country to deal with it will start
in the house and once it gets to the
senate the bite administration will push
the senate to do two things at once
do the trial and do the legislation and
the confirmations we'll see if they can
do it major thank you very much
sure just exhausted by it all thank you
very much major